foreign
[Music]
I find out how we can share energy with
a country 450 miles away
[Music]
and Thomas visits the science museum to
see how science fiction can become
reality
[Music]
welcome to FYI the Weekly News show
where we bring you all the latest info
and all the big stories and one of the
things we've been looking at this week
is that judges at the international
criminal court have said that Vladimir
Putin Russia's President should be
arrested for war crimes but what's this
all about well we've been investigating
the international criminal court known
as the ICC was created to ensure that
people responsible for the worst crimes
are brought to Justice this includes
crimes against humanity and genocide
which is a crime committed with the
intent to destroy a national ethnic
racial or religious group
foreign
the ICC say both President Putin and
Russia's commissioner for children's
rights Maria Nova belovar should be
arrested
it's all because of a report by United
Nations which says the way some
Ukrainian children have been treated is
a war crime
the United Nations often called the UN
is a worldwide organization that brings
countries together to talk about and try
to agree on world issues
so what exactly is a war crime well I've
been reading up on that so it's when a
country breaks an international law
that's been agreed on by all the other
countries about what you can and cannot
do in Wartime one of these laws include
anyone who's not involved in the
fighting must be protected which
includes children the un's report says
there's evidence that thousands of
Ukrainian children have been taken away
from Ukraine against their will by
Russian forces
many of them have been forced to live
with Russian families despite still
having parents in Ukraine
the report also says many of these
children are being treated very badly
this goes against international law and
is considered a war crime Putin and
Russia have denied committing any war
crimes and so that the Court's decision
has no significance whatsoever so what
does this mean for President Putin well
nothing immediately although he may be
arrested if he decides to travel to any
of the 122 other countries that are a
part of the international criminal court
however it does mean that he's been
labeled as a suspected war criminal for
the rest of his life and this will
affect how we've seen by his own country
and the rest of the world
[Music]
so if your parents recently been
bothering you I don't know to turn off
the lights switch off your computer or
even unplug your hairdryer yeah my dad's
always telling me to turn off the lights
my mum's always telling me to turn off
my game console and not leave it on for
too long yeah I mean everything's
getting so more expensive at the moment
including our energy bills yeah and plus
aren't we supposed to be using less
energy to help save the environment
right so how do we keep powering all
these electrical things without damaging
the environment and costing our parents
lots of money well I went to
Northumberland to find out
here
it's very windy exactly the best day to
come to the beach but the wind is
proving very handy because over there we
have wind turbines and so much wind it's
making the blaze turn around
pretty cool hey
but I've heard that not all electricity
is made like this so I thought I'd find
someone who could tell me a bit more hey
Mike hey jariah not all electricity or
energy comes from wind some energy has
actually come from what we call fossil
fuels like gas oil and coal which we
then burn at big Power stations now
fossil fuels or dinosaurs and effect
prehistoric plants and animals now the
issue with those are fossil fuels before
long will all die out so once they're
gone they're gone you're absolutely
right burning fossil fuels you'll meet
lots of greenhouse gases which isn't
great for our environment so that's why
we've got to get better at using
sustainable green energy so creating
energy that doesn't run out like using
wind yes like using wind absolutely if
you listen to other noise around us you
can hear a little bit of a buzz yeah
that is actually because the station's
in operation wow but what happens if
it's not windy anymore so I've got a job
for you if you come this way
so drier there is multiple ways you can
generate energy but this is one of them
if you kept going for seven minutes you
would generate enough electricity to
power a mobile tablet for an hour this
is really really hard but there are
better ways it's all dryer over there
we've got a country called Norway wow
and Norway I've got so much water they
can change it in their energy it's
called hydropower hydropower is created
by the flow of water and rivers and
oceans can we share our energies but you
should ask that
so dry this is really cool so when you
talk about sharing of energy elsewhere
right this cable actually caused 450
miles from the uh
exactly to Norway and we don't see it
again to this point until it gets into
Norway so we are currently the longest
subsident connector in the world what
that allows us to do is when our wind's
not blowing we can bring in Hydro power
from Norway which is clean sustainable
energy and likewise when the water
levels are low in Norway we can support
them by providing them with our wind and
our solar energy which is great for each
country to help and share energy to keep
you guys playing on your computer
devices well if it's so long it must
have to be a really strong cable it's a
very strong cable and I've got a bit
here just to show you what it's like so
this bit in the center here is where the
electricity travels through but because
it sits under the sea and there's things
like ships that go and put anchors down
or shipping troll as with Nets we've got
to have various different levels of
protection so it doesn't break in the
last thing we want to do is have to go
down and keep fixing these cables so how
much energy is being provided so what's
amazing about this interconnector is it
gives us enough energy to supply 1.4
million ohms
that is amazing
[Music]
check this out a dedicated dad wanted to
remember every moment of his son's
childhood so we took a photo of him
every day from the day he was born all
the way up until he was 21. his son then
took over the project and has continued
to take a daily snap of himself with the
hope of capturing a whole lifetime how
cool is that
[Music]
can you tell if this surprising
scientific trivia is fake news or fact
experts claim that the Mariana Trench
the deepest point on Earth can hold the
whole of Mount Everest the tallest
mountain in the world inside it but
could that possibly be true
find out later
[Music]
people living in Scotland are about to
get a new first Minister who will run
the Scottish government yes because
Nicholas sturgeon has recently announced
her resignation after eight years in
charge and so today I am announcing my
intention to step down as first Minister
and leader of my party but what does the
first Minister actually do and why is it
such a big deal well we've been checking
it out Nicholas sturgeon was the head of
the Scottish government which has the
power to make its own decisions on
things like education policing and the
Health Service
but the UK government still has powers
over things like Scotland's money and
the Armed Forces
Nicholas sturgeon was also the leader of
the SNP the Scottish national party it's
a political party which wants Scotland
to be completely independent from the
rest of the UK a public vote known as a
referendum was held in 2014 on whether
Scotland should become independent but
most people who voted wanted to stay as
part of the UK
it's up to members of the SNP to vote
for who they want as their first
minister so who's in the running well
we've all been looking into this and we
found out there are three people who put
themselves forward the first is Hamza
Yusuf he's currently Scotland's house
secretary and is a Scottish Pakistani so
could become the first Muslim man in
charge of Scotland
next is Kate Forbes who's the Covenant
secretary for finance and the economy
but she lost some support in the SMP
because she said she wouldn't have voted
in favor of gay marriage
lastly is Ash Regan he says she is the
best person to lead Scotland to
Independence
well it's time to get your shout on this
we headed to Common old Academy in North
selection to hear from an FYI News Club
there who they think the next first
Minister should be and if Scott ninja
become independent
to be honest I wouldn't want them to be
an absolute dafty when they're like
doing speeches in that I wouldn't want
them to
kind of start any arguments with any
other countries
the qualities I'd like to see in my new
first Minister I'd like to see someone
that would put people first as like a
main priority I hope someone who comes
in that is like dependent and like good
and mixed decisions that it's not only
good for them but it's good for like
Scotland like a kind one like
it's a nice nice person very nice person
do you think smaller should be
independent
um no because our economy is an average
police right now but if Scotland went
independent then our economy would go
downhill do you think we should go in
with him uh yeah I do because if
Scotland school is independent then
maybe we'll be able to do more with our
land but like yes and no because like if
we we're an independent country we'd be
like shortage on money the last time
there was a referendum I was four at the
time so it just proves how much times
can change oh how often when it last was
yeah so let's just hope this new person
will bring Scotland its independence
[Music]
if you have a story and want to report
on FYI get in touch via our webpage or
even better get your teachers to set up
an FYI News Club at your school members
can get the chance to report for us and
we'll even help you film your story and
you can watch and discuss the latest
episodes with free resources every week
so did you manage to work up this week's
fake news or facts we told you that
experts think the deepest part of the
ocean on earth the Mariana Trench could
hold the whole of Mount Everest inside
it well it's a fact the Mariana Trench
in the Pacific Ocean is whopping 11 034
meters deep
in contrast Mount Everest which borders
Nepal and China sits at 8 849 meters
above the sea level so it would fit
inside the Mariana Trench with room to
spare
cool
for once spiders don't make me squealed
this amazing picture
so a photographer in Indonesia managed
to snap this jumping spider in his
garden surrounded by water droplets
it looks like it's doing a fashion shoot
for a colorful hat cool
well spiders aren't the only fashion
conscious creatures I never knew until I
saw this but scientists believe that the
sea urchins use stones and shells to
cover their heads to camouflage
themselves from predators or to protect
themselves from the sun's harmful rays
to prove this some 3D printed hats were
left in the water for these urchins and
this was the result
because the hats are plastic they were
removed after the experiment
so are you guys into science fiction
well sort of I mean I like science when
we do it at school well have you
wondered if science fiction can turn
into actual science Thomas went to
investigate
[Music]
so just how much science fiction
actually becomes a reality I'm here at
the science museum to explore the
relationship between science fiction and
actual science
[Music]
no guys I haven't left the planet I'm
not friends with Jeff Bezos or Elon Musk
but this is the next best thing
Voyage the edge of imagination is not
your typical science exhibition because
it is science fiction that's on display
here
it contains nine sections of an alien
ship where you come across items from
famous science fiction films books and
television shows
this is the bio app which explores how
scientists have been inspired by
technology that they've seen in films or
TV shows and tried to develop them for
real like these bionic arms
now today's scientists have not quite
mastered a jump gate a doorway to
another world across space shame
what do you want people to get out of
the exhibition the main thing I hope
people would take away is that they'd
just be excited about the possibilities
that science fiction brings to science
the exhibition is all about that
inspiration and you know we're showing
that science and science fiction Inspire
each other that it's a conversation
between the two what can science fiction
do for the world and how can it affect
the environment for the good the way
that science fiction encourages us to
think creatively to think imaginatively
and to try and solve problems in new
ways and we can apply those to some of
the challenges that are facing the world
such as climate change what I hope
science fiction shows generally is that
there are many possibilities infinite
possibilities and it's kind of up to us
which ones of those become the real
future
wow that was such a surreal experience
and it felt like I was in a different
world and it's amazing to see what
science fiction can do for actual
science
well that's it for this week we wanted
to leave you some of the amazing winning
pictures of the rspb young British
wildlife photographer of the Year Awards
see you next time bye
[Music]
foreign